près d'amis virgule 3 millions de
personnes en France c'est quelque chose
de très important
ça montre en tout cas une détermination
qu'on sentait je crois que le
gouvernement n'a pas été surpris autant
peut-être la première fois il y avait un
virgule un million à peu près là on en
avait 150000 de plus aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il a été un petit peu surpris
je crois qu'il l'avait anticipé je pense
que les propos d'Elisabeth borne juste
avant pour marquer la fermeture les 64
ans c'est non négociable on est
véritablement c'est peut-être le
sentiment que je ressens ce soir arriver
à ce moment où on est vraiment dans le
face à face de cette grande bagarre des
retraites la rue est mobilisée les
Français quand ils sont fondés sont
majoritairement contre le passage de
l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans enfin si
un gouvernement qui s'est organisé il y
a eu plein de ratés on en reparlera
probablement des ratés de communication
ils montrent une fermeté un moment et je
pense qu'on en parlera également où on
sent un peu de flottement déjà dans la
majorité déjà chez les républicains
alliés de circonstances donc j'ai envie
de dire ce 31 janvier est à mon avis une
date assez clé dans cette dans cette
grande bagarre de la réforme des
retraites est-ce qu'on peut être contre
sans s'y opposer
oui
déjà honnêtement quand on vous dit à
n'importe qui d'ailleurs vous allez
travailler deux ans de plus c'est rare
qu'on disait c'est rare qu'on dise oui
c'est comme si on vous demandait si vous
allez être moins payé donc c'est rare
effectivement d'avoir une approbation ce
qui fait que je suis très peu surpris
finalement par le nombre important de
gens qui s'opposent à cette réforme
encore qu'il est de 60 et quelques pour
cent en même temps ce qui est
intéressant je trouve là-dedans c'est
qu'on a quand même des Français assez
réalistes
à se démocratique où il y a 68% qui
disent mais ça passera quand même oui
c'est ça
je suis contre je sais que cette loi de
toute façon on pourra rien faire donc
c'est un peu c'est un peu ça alors après
je pense qu'on y reviendra d'ailleurs il
y a une communication que je trouve
assez lamentable du gouvernement sur la
pédagogie à faire on y parle tous
maintenant de pédagogie puis on faisait
pas au dernier moment qu'on fait la
pédagogie c'est quelque chose qui se
fait dans le clan donc là effectivement
il y a une grande faiblesse le fait que
Elizabeth borde et puis dire dimanche je
crois mais soutenu par le Président
c'est 64 ans et c'est non négociable bon
ça ça fixait le débat appuyez par le
Président de la République derrière
indispensable ça c'est très important ça
c'est très important parce que les
réformes qui ont été faites sur les
retraites les années antérieures depuis
20 ans et un peu plus d'ailleurs
sont toutes passées parce qu'il y avait
un accord du président et celle de 95
c'est parce que le président Chirac à
l'époque avait cédé après une rencontre
avec Marc Blondel je crois de FO et donc
avait lâché Juppé c'est pour ça qu'il le
truc c'était arrêté là on a de toute
façon un président dont le programme se
résume à peu près à cette mesure même si
on peut revenus à 65 ans donc s'il le
fait pas et bien écoutez on peut lui
faire un pot de départ très sympathique
mais ça a pu lieu d'être la seule chose
qui avait dans son programme donc vous
comprenez qu'il est obligé de tenir
c'est tenir ou partir c'est ça alors
Dina elle a voulu s'affirmer
politiquement dimanche la première
ministre en disant c'est pas négociable
elle avait un ton qui est pas martial
mais un ton très affirmé en disant c'est
comme ça c'est pas autrement on voit de
toute façon depuis le début de sa
nomination que qu'elle s'affirme quand
même régulièrement elle tient plutôt
bien son poste de chef de la majorité
d'ailleurs beaucoup n'aurait pas donné
cher de sa peau à l'été et puis
finalement elle a montré une certaine
une certaine résistance voir une
certaine résilience et là en effet le
moment est un peu complexe parce que
c'est soit comme vous le disiez soit on
s'accroche parce qu'en fait c'est une
affaire personnelle pour Emmanuel Macron
cette réforme c'est peut-être la seule
chose pour laquelle on retiendra et si
demain il lâche sur ça le macronisme
c'est terminé quoi d'une certaine
manière déjà qu'on n'est pas sûr que ça
va perdurer au-delà de lui c'est
compliqué de lâcher là dessus donc en
effet il a fallu qu'elle repose un petit
peu les termes du débat en insistant sur
le fait que que cette partie est non
négociable à un moment où les troupes
commençaient aussi un petit peu à se
disperser ça j'imagine qu'on en
reparlera mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait
il y avait besoin je pense de te
remettre un petit peu de clarté dans la
majorité de rappeler que les députés ont
quand même fait campagne sur cette
réforme et en même temps c'est aussi
prendre le risque que d'ajouter de
l'attention à de l'attention puisque
c'est c'est verrouillé un peu la
négociation au moment
les gens descendent dans la rue en
espérant en espérant réussir à ouvrir au
moment où Gabriel Attal disait que les
négociations étaient encore ouvertes que
la discussion était encore possible bon
bah là voilà on monte bien que sur ce
point c'est pas possible le reste ça se
négocie mais là dessus non parce qu'en
fait c'est l'identité la crédibilité
d'une certaine manière d'Emmanuel Macron
qui repose dans cette région
il a raison Philippe en disant
finalement la pédagogie elle n'a pas été
faite
a toujours raison je crois
la pédagogie a pas été faite et puis
même pire plus le gouvernement
plus on découvre plus le grand public
découvre des aspects de la loi moins il
comprend je prends l'exemple des femmes
des mamans des mères pour savoir à quel
âge enfin combien d'années en fait vont
être ajoutées à la carrière d'une mère
c'est pas évident il faut monter un
simulateur en fait ça varie en fonction
des cas de tout le monde de chacun donc
pour certaines effectivement ça fait
quatre ans de plus pour certaines ça
fait rien parce qu'elles ont commencé à
travailler tard plus elles sont
diplômées moins ça fait le
truc est tellement complexe pour quelque
chose qui est en fait finalement qui
aurait dû être assez simple que c'est
incompréhensible à l'arrivée et c'est
elle s'explique pas simplement donc
quelque part il y a un manque de
pédagogie et puis au début on disait pas
les mers on disait les femmes mais
toutes les femmes sont pas mère enfin
c'était pas clair après
les carrières fractionnées alors
d'accord donc c'est à dire que toutes
les femmes ont des carrières
fractionnées le discours de cet aspect
là en tout cas a pas été clair et on
peut le dupliquer sur beaucoup d'autres
exemples en fait et pourtant et pourtant
et c'est peut-être d'ailleurs une des
motifs aussi de flottement c'est qu'il y
a 6 ans nous avons dû cette réforme en
disant priorité c'est de rassembler tous
les régimes en un seul régime là j'étais
pas une priorité loin de là à l'époque
c'était ça les Français justement ils se
disent ils sont gentils à l'exécutif
mais il flotte il nous donne une une
imposition qui finalement
est contestable puisque elle n'existait
pas il y a quelques années oui moi je
pense que au-delà de la pédagogie alors
moi je partage pas tout à fait ce qui a
été dit pas sur le fond mais en tout cas
je pense que la pédagogie on en entend
parler depuis des années cette réforme
en revanche c'est le louvoiement en
permanent en train de réforme systémique
d'un côté une réforme paramétrique
aujourd'hui hier il fallait surtout pas
de paramétrer
aujourd'hui il nous faut du paramétrer
mais il y a le corps qui nous dit mais
il faut peut-être pas c'est pas si
simple que ça c'est ça finalement je
crois que là la pédagogie en tout cas
c'est la conviction qui est compliqué on
a du mal à être convaincu parce que on
sait plus très bien
donc c'est plutôt là-dessus je pense
qu'on passe surpris les Français en
revanche ils savent plus très bien
pourquoi on fait cette règle on va les
écouter d'ailleurs les les artistes les
acteurs du dossier
bon alors François Ruffin qui dit que
grosso modo l'exécutif ce sont des
incompétents et leur en berger le patron
de la CFDT qui est appelé d'ailleurs à
bientôt aussi des sa place et ce n'est
pas anodin non plus dans le débat qui
dit nous tout va bien on est déterminés
et on veut pas du tout lui était
d'accord d'ailleurs avec le systémique
il y a un an il y a 5 ans et maintenant
il a est-ce que c'est une réflexion
qu'on entend et d'ailleurs dans le
Figaro de demain vous allez pouvoir
entendre lire slide enquête intéressante
on dit que le Président de la République
et la première ministre
sont pas entourés comme les terres
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2010 comme l'était
comme l'était François Fillon et en
Raffarin François
en 2004
il y a peu de l'Arsène là s'il vous
plaît je crois qu'il y a un sujet sur
l'équipe gouvernementale dans sa
globalité c'est vrai que depuis ce
deuxième quinquennat alors déjà l'équipe
autour d'Emmanuel Macron a changé son
conseiller a changé la communication a
changé et l'équipe de manière générale
on voit aujourd'hui
que très peu de ministres sont
identifiés je pense que si on demande
aux Français de nommer des ministres à
part les Bruno Le Maire Darmanin Attal
mais voilà une poignée de 5,6 qu'on
arrive à peu près à identifier le reste
on ne les connaît pas parce qu'Emmanuel
Macron a aussi fait des choix qui était
de nommer des ministres assez peu
politiques aussi parce que à son arrivée
à son arrivée pour la deuxième fois à
l'Élysée il avait plein un très grand
choix aussi de de possibilités d'options
d'options à nommé au gouvernement et en
fait on arrive dans un dans une équipe
dont la communication
est très technique manque de politique
on a un peu un gouvernement de techno de
partenaires et ça ça a des conséquences
aussi sur la communication globale par
rapport aux Français on parlait de
pédagogie
tout à l'heure j'étais au téléphone par
exemple avec avec Jean-François Copé qui
qui se remémorait à son époque les
grands ténors de la politique qui était
sur le front pour défendre la réforme on
parle pas du tout des mêmes
personnalités qu'aujourd'hui et on le
voit aussi dans dans la communication
vous prenez Elisabeth borde quand elle a
présenté la réforme des retraites on est
quand même sur un sujet qui est
profondément technique parce que c'est
très compliqué mais aussi profondément
humain on touche à la retraite des gens
qui est quelque chose qui est vécu comme
un privilège qui aujourd'hui est dans un
moment où le débat sur le travail est
très important c'est capital et quand
vous regardez la présentation ça a coûté
un ces robotique si on a l'impression
qu'elle lit son prompteur c'est pas
c'est pas animé c'est pas incarné et
c'est une des grandes difficultés de
cette réforme aussi c'est qu'elle n'est
pas incarnée et ça et ça rejoint tout le
procès de déconnexion et
[Rires]
[Musique]
bien sachant qu'il y a déjà François
Bayonne
et entendre ces dissonances
ils sont pas aidés par les voix
alors c'est terrible parce que certains
confrères toujours bien
intentionnés sont allés sortir des sons
quand il était socialiste et où il
disait évidemment pique pendre de un
allongement de l'âge de dirai à la
retraite on peut évoluer la politique on
évolue beaucoup c'est très rude non mais
je crois d'ailleurs dinal disait très
justement au-delà même des conseillers
du président de la République on n'a pas
le plus le personnel politique des
députés les hommes les responsables
politiques qui sont capables d'aller
voir le président et de lui dire écoute
ça faudrait le voir comme ça se faire
les relais dinal le disait très
justement il a pas vraiment de relais et
même moi je suis très frappé dans ce
gouvernement par le côté techno ça on
vient de le dire vrai techno il n'y
avait de borne c'est quand même c'est
une
mais par le fait on arrive même pas à
les imiter
jusque là les politiques qui avaient
toujours quand on regarde un
gouvernement on se moquait de l'accent
hein de la manière de parler d'un autre
même pas on peut pas ils sont lisses ils
sont lisses c'est ce sont des
techniciens qui sont bons dans leur
partie ils connaissent parfaitement la
technique et comme toute technicien vous
savez moi je suis dans un milieu
d'ingénieurs un ingénieur il fixe son
truc pour lui dire n'importe quoi lui il
accélère il a fixé son truc point barre
il regarde pas sur les côtés alors je
les adore par ailleurs parce que s'ils
ont des convictions etc mais mais là ça
passe pas on retient rien et et il a
raison de Darmanin ce week-end mais oui
mais alors lui voilà lui c'est un
prototype parce que lui mais parce que
il faut aussi pouvoir dire un peu
lâcher des mots effectivement dire ça
suffit le bordel etc ça on aime bien
regarder les figures dont on se souvient
en politique c'est des figures qui qui
parlaient avec un accent
extraordinaire il avait à la fois non
seulement l'accent mais le don de la
formule
j'étais des hommes de formule là non et
finalement c'est ça une des faiblesses
c'est pour ça qu'on disait je je vais
essayer de réconcilier Jacquie et Elsa
sur la pédagogie la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il y a de la
pédagogie mais elle est elle est
technique et là elle savait raison elle
est tellement technique d'un seul coup
il se mette mais ils adorent ça faut
jamais les lancer sur la technique c'est
ce qui préfère c'est des techno donc
vous les lancez sur sur les femmes
attendez même le système enfin le
paramétrique etc mais il y a pas un
français qui a compris ce que c'était le
systémique là celle-là on comprend le
systémique alors là c'était là c'était
la retraite par point alors là c'était
dernière question avant de passer
justement bah la technique la technique
parlementaire oh là là est-ce que le
Président de la République
euh doit garder une réserve complète
pour le moment parce que borne c'est le
fusible et que lui doit arriver quand
même quand ça va vraiment chauffer quoi
si ça chauffe c'est c'est l'habitude non
de garder une réserve et d'avoir un
fusil il a il a comme il a commencé un
petit peu mais
en disant que c'était pas l'endroit où
s'exprimer donc ce qui est une façon de
dire qu'il a les exprimer même si
c'était pas l'endroit mais oui oui
évidemment il garde une certaine
distance et puis si jamais il faut faire
une petite marche arrière lâcher du lest
j'y crois pas beaucoup mais c'est
évident qu'un premier ministre c'est
c'est un fusible c'est le message est
assez clair et d'ailleurs le peu
d'implication d'Emmanuel Macron montre à
quel point Elisabeth borne est amené à
être fusible au cas où ou même si ça
passe elle peut servir de fusible en
disant bon bah bon maintenant on
l'enlève parce qu'elle a été trop loin
on sait pas dans quel sens ça peut jouer
[Musique]